the opening scene is set in the Year
1961 in notz Mississippi where we are
introduced to a wealthy businessman
named Mr Van Weir he owns a toy company
and is currently seen interviewing a
lady named Kobe dhum for the position of
his secretary during the interview Mr
wart tells her about how God sought
Perfection while creating humans from
dust he believes that a plastic doll is
incapable of sinning since it doesn't
have a soul and that if humans were like
dolls God would be even more happy but
they all so wouldn't get anything done
after reviewing Kobe's resume Mr Weir
tells her that she isn't fit for this
job despite her excellent records when
she tries to protest a guy grabs her
from behind and the camera pans out a
while later Kobe regains her
Consciousness and finds herself in a
house surrounded by human-sized dolls
soon after Mr Weir welcomes her to his
very own custom-designed dollhouse and
explains that she will be there for the
next 7 days he goes on to say that her
qualifications were too good for for the
position of secretary which is why he
has hired her as a pageant hearing this
she says that she has no interest in the
position but he tells her that she has
no other choice in a state of panic Kobe
tries to run away but she is stopped by
Mr we's guard Eustace who can't speak
due to the lack of a tongue as Mr Weir
prepares to leave Kobe pleads not to be
left alone to which he claims that she
won't be not long after Kobe learns that
the human-sized dolls are in fact real
people they're simply dressed like dolls
wearing face masks and maintaining a
statuesque position Kobe asks about what
is going on and one of the human dolls
named aelia tells her that she has been
abducted by a crazy toy maker who is
obsessed with dolls according to her Mr
Weir is looking for a perfect doll in
order to find a mother for his son otus
vanir for this he forces them to perform
various tests as part of a pageant ones
who do not measure up will get
eliminated in the worst way another
human doll named Harley advises Kobe to
take some rest before she is assigned
with her first task however Kobe
continues to check the doors and windows
as she is only interested in getting out
of here harleen says that she
understands what Kobe is going through
because she also reacted the same way
when she was first brought here Kobe
wonders if the law wouldn't suspect if
everyone who interviewed disappeared in
response harlene explains that they all
come from different backgrounds Aurelia
was a dancer Fay was a kindergarten
teacher and Bonnie was directly abducted
from her home harleen goes on to say
that their efforts of escaping are
useless because this place is built like
a safe as their conversation unfolds
harleen reveals about Otis's mother
named Ellen who died two years ago the
official story states that she drowned
in a swamp but Kobe realizes that it's
not true harleen then discloses the real
incident Mr we caught his wife making
out with another guy as a result he
ordered eustus to throw both of them
into a well since that tragic event Mr
we has been determined to find an ideal
mother for his son this makes Kobe
realize that winning the pageant is the
only way to get out of this mess their
conversation is abruptly interrupted by
a loud bell ringing harleen hastily
instructs Kobe to put on an outfit take
up a position and stay still until she's
asked to move a short while later Otis
walks in and talks to the new doll Kobe
he tells her that he hates clowns and
decides to order Eustace to dispose of
Kobe in order to save herself she shows
him a magic trick in which she makes his
firet truck roll on its own here it is
revealed that Kobe actually possesses a
telekinetic ability and that she can
move things with her mind this leaves
the boy greatly impressed he
goes later that night aelia asks Kobe
how she made the firetruck move to which
she replies that she learned it from her
uncle who used to do magic tricks
Aurelia appears to be jealous and
accuses her of lying to win the pageant
Kobe claims that she doesn't want to be
Otis's mother because it would also mean
being Mr we's wife however Aurelia
believes that winning this would give
her enough time to come up with an
escape plan as they Converse an alarm
goes off which implies that it is time
for a test following this Mr we gets all
of them seated across the dining table
and discloses a menu crawfish Cardinal
and terrain soup how does anyone know
what the hell terrain is he then asks
them to set up the Crockery correctly
within a minute if they succeed they
will be considered as a perfect
housewife everyone begins to arrange the
table in a hurry desperate to win the
task Aurelia pulls off the perfect
setting unlike Kobe who knocks over a
water glass as she tries to copy what
the others are doing after the time
expires Mr Weir holds a cattle prod in
his hand while inspecting each of the
Dolls table settings Aurelia passes the
test while harlene and Kobe receive two
and four points respectively meanwhile
Fay makes the biggest mistakes so she is
stunned by the cattle prod before being
thrown down the well this indicates how
high the stakes are and how perfect each
doll needs to be for their continued
survival the following morning Otis
again visits the dollhouse and plays
with Kobe she shows the same magic trick
of making his fir trck move when the
boys ask further about this trick Kobe
admits that it was a gift from birth she
says that she is different from others
just like Otis who does not go to school
and plays with dolls this prompts the
boy to reveal that he stopped going to
school after being bullied by his
classmates as well as his teachers oh
little Otis I can't imagine why as their
conversation progresses Otis expresses
that he wants Kobe to be his new mom in
response once she promises to be the
best mom if he convinces his father to
free the other dolls convinced by her
words Otis goes to talk to his father
that night as he walks down the hallway
he overhears his father talking on the
phone asking for more time to increase
the sale of his hand sewn dolls seeing
him in a horrible mood Otis hesitates to
bring up this topic the next day the
bell rings and the ladies hurriedly put
on their costumes shortly after Mr we
enters the dollhouse and announces their
next test to pass this test the human
dolls must blend an ironing spray and
fold a shirt in a perfect manner before
the task begins he provides a brief
history of mons sedu the owner of doine
Street Laundry as the 3-minute timer
Begins the ladies start working
frantically after the time elapses Mr we
evaluates their work starting with
harlene who receives three points upon
inspecting Kobe's shirt he finds it
excessively stiff as well as scorched as
a punishment for this he forces her to
place her hand on the ironing board and
then presses it with a hot iron despite
the excruciating pain Kobe does not
utter a single word Aurelia passes the
test as usual while Bonnie is eliminated
for her shirt emitting a foul odor I
said shirt not says Mr we Mr we
then informs the remaining dolls that
there will be a final task tomorrow and
the one who excels in it will be
declared the winner in the aftermath of
this event Harlen helps Kobe intending
to her wounds during this she mentions
that Mr Weir has a liking for Kobe since
he could have eliminated her for
scorching that shirt in the meantime
time Aurelia EES drops on their
conversation and decides to murder Kobe
for this she grabs a pointed metal Spike
and heads upstairs to Kobe's room she
stabs the spike through the clown
costume only to discover that it is just
a mannequin just then harleen and Kobe
appear from behind revealing that they
were already aware of her plan how who
cares this infuriates aelia who explains
that she doesn't want to die Kobe
responds that neither of them have to
die because she has an escape plan and
that they can walk through the front
door Aurelia warns that Eustace will
hunt them down but Kobe assures her that
they can make it before their secret
plan gets revealed the following day the
three ladies dress up the mannequins in
doll costumes while they hide themselves
behind curtains a short while later Mr
Weir along with Eustace comes to the
dollhouse in order to announce their
final task while Mr Weir Converses with
the mannequins Kobe uses her telekinetic
ability to unlock the exit door and the
trio slip out of the dollhouse once
outside Kobe has a change of heart and
decides to fulfill promised to become
Otis's best mother why Aurelia and
harlene choose not to waste any more
time there and make a run for it while
Kobe enters Mr we's mansion in search of
Otis on the other hand Mr we asks a
Biblical question but when he does not
receive any answers he finally realizes
that they are mannequins in the Mansion
Kobe locates Otis and asks him to
accompany her because his father is a
sick man but in an unexpected turn of
events the boy stuns her with a cattle
prod monkey see monkey do causing her to
collapse meanwhile harleen trips and
falls so she pleads with Aurelia for
help however Aurelia intends to kill her
for being too slow and loud she grabs a
large Rock to smash her head but at the
same time she is shot from behind by
Eustace who then kills harleen as well
afterwards Kobe regains Consciousness
and finds herself restrained to a table
Mr we stands beside her and
congratulates her for winning the
pageant he reveals that Otis's vintage
doll has a porcelain head with a hearing
device planted in it which is how he
learned of their plan as a result he
devised a final test of faith to see who
would risk their lives for his son after
this Revelation a large doll mold is
pressed against Kobe's body encasing her
in porcelain her distress causes her
telekinetic abilities to flicker the
lights but it's not strong enough to
help her Escape in the next scene Kobe
and her doll form is seen serving tea to
Mr weer and otus at this moment two
robed women appear in front of them they
are revealed to be the witches from Mr
robish Show's Academy they used their
power to freeze Mr Weir and Eustace and
break the dll mold setting Kobe free a
young witch explains that they would
have arrived earlier but Kobe's spells
were too weak Kobe appears puzzled so
the witches clarify that she is one of
them and they are here to rescue her
Otis pleads with them to not leave him
behind so Kobe agrees to take him along
on the condition that he will never
return to his father as they leave the
witches burn down Mr weird Eustace and
the dollhous with a flick of their hands
in the final scene we see Kobe dropping
Otis off at Miss robas Show's Academy
before departing she suggests that he
use a different name for his own safety
just then a girl approaches her and otus
introduces himself as Spalding before
heading inside with her subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching